we're learning new details about the
case of an airline mechanic accused of
sabotaging an American Airlines jetliner
prosecutors say evidence unveiled at the
suspects bail hearing revealed he stored
Isis videos on his phone and made
statements wishing Allah would harm
non-muslims Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport outside watching him
Chris what else do we know about the
suspect oh good morning he is a rocky
born but a naturalized US citizen as an
airline mechanic he passed regular
background checks and had no criminal
record at the time of his arrest but
certainly these new allegations are
going to raise new questions about the
vetting process around everyone who
works near airplanes accused of
sabotaging an American Airlines flight
60 year old mechanic Abdul Majeed Marouf
Ahmed Alani remains behind bars after a
federal judge cited new evidence Aulani
could be sympathetic to terrorists the
judge denied bail deeming him a danger
and a flight risk
Haru Ingram is a former counterterrorism
officer the insider threat is obviously
something which counterterrorism
officers are going to be very very
concerned about on July 17th Alani
allegedly superglued styrofoam inside
the nose of this American Airlines 737
interfering with the planes navigation
systems as the plane taxied to the
runway in Miami pilots got an alert the
plane with 150 on board did not take off
no one was hurt it is significant
anytime we reject a takeoff that's a big
deal Aulani said he was upset about
stalled contract talks between his Union
and the airline which had affected him
financially but prosecutors now claim he
shared videos stored on his cell phone
of Isis murders had recently sent money
to someone in Iraq has a brother there
who may have ties to the Islamic state
and recently traveled to his native
country clearly there are more questions
that are raised by these details that
then answers and I think the right step
to a mate today
Ilana's public defender argued for bail
saying his client never intentionally
put anybody in any danger because the
plane had backup systems now Aulani is
facing up to 20 years behind bars for
sabotage but it's important to note is
not currently facing any terror related
charges American Airlines is cooperating
with the investigation
Tony Chris thank you